we gotta find that christmas song folks
we
must it is our duty and i said duty
um all right so they sent me this one
waiting for christmas catalina
catalina sweet music catalina sweet
music
[Music]
merry christmas
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
christmas music sex
christmas music here folks
[Music]
rob can she get it can somebody ask rob
if she can get it
[Music]
is
here i am getting ready for the holy
night
[Music]
nope
nope no on that one
uh let's see this one is
mahogany locks mary litmus
mary litmus okay
all right fireplace i don't have the
fireplace tonight's the night girl
tonight's the night oh i already hate
her though
yeah you know he has a lot of names but
i call him nick you know it rhymes with
nick right dick is it dick
is it dick is it dick hey guys in the
toilet before i play
he's a dick guys guys
guys is it dick
is it dick
i think it's dick
i need your help here is it dick
i see his candy cane do you know what
i'm saying
i know i know it's naughty i know
but you know sometimes you know when
you're in love
what time is it
oh girl i gotta go to bed he's gonna be
here soon
yeah happy holidays bye
[Music]
a few moments later
are we going to get to the song
and i've seen some jews about this all
right let's see what we got
here oh yeah
ew
is that really her face
[Music]
oh god it's doing the crunching the
cookie crunching noise again
what is this
600 000 subscribers just so you guys
know
[Music]
a happy new year
[Music]
you better lay them cookies out cause we
coming for you
we wish you a merry little miss
[Music]
and a happy new year still think women
should vote
it's christmas time and i'm here to get
crazy doing what i want cause santa
that's me my baby
we always wow rudolph he leads the way
and i wanna get drunk i'm sorry mrs
claus
i had to let you know but santa your
mans he's a ho ho
female empowerment folks female
empowerment
brought to you by mahogany locks
mahogany locks
making a viral christmas song happy
holidays
eww happy holidays y'all it's your
money locks and today i'm doing
something i've never done this channel
and i'm
so excited we are doing maintaining a
meaningful relationship with people
around you
24 hour song challenge and it's holiday
edition
why is maybe from arrested development
becoming a rapper now
oh how
yeah you are very excited
this video is going to be super fun
because future me which is me right now
is going to be narrating you through all
the steps of how we make our songs and
how we made this specific song
sorry about it um christmas charlie
brown
um nobody needs a windscreen that big
nobody yeah whoa
i've been good santa no have it
santa i've been naughty but i swear i
can't be nice i'll throw it back baby
for stocking full of ice you have a
single bed
in your studio apartment if this doesn't
work out you could always
[ __ ] a guy that looks like cartman not a
great rapper folks i apologize
i'm gonna just leave here i think i'm
done with this one
uh all right so this one is real like
you
join us by the christmas tree
oh i love hand tattoos those are my
favorite kind of tattoos
[Music]
and i'm not the only one
[Music]
just wait and see
[Music]
i know i don't want dollar short
destiny's shout sing christmas song
no thank you nope nope nope nope
nope nope and also
no
i think at this point you guys are
sending me remember we're looking for a
good christmas song
oh can we tell this one's going to be
great this is
beth j crowley
the day we've met is one that i will
always remember saw you
at a bakery last year in december
it felt like a movie
i hated you at first but you eventually
wooed me
though you said the holidays are too
overrated
so when you dumped me back in august it
was totally tragic
[Music]
congratulations
you ruined christmas i never
thought i'd have a reason to start
hating my
favorite season i should be jolly you
got dumped in august and that ruined
christmas for you
get over it
[Music]
that's a really good point brian's got a
point women can only write about men
it's actually hilarious you're right it
is hilarious
you can't even do songs if they're not
about men tyler prax ain't lonely
christmas
[Music]
i already hate this over singing
[ __ ] we haven't gotten the song yet
but i hate that whole like
she's probably won since the national
anthem goes and the home of the
break
[Music]
[ __ ] say brave and leave i want to
watch the [ __ ] football game